Speaker 1: This is one of my favorite stories
of the year.
It's up there when with when Alex Jones attacked
me.
Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell, also known to many
of us as Mike Pillow or simply pillow, spent
hours on our Facebook page attacking me in
comments and arguing with many of you.
Viewers wrote to me and said, David Pillow
is in the comments on your YouTube channel
and he's attacking you and he's attacking
us and he's calling people bots.
You have to see this.
And I said, weighted pillow is worth $300
million.
He's running a pillow business, which now
sells coffee and it sells slippers and bathrobes
and all.
There's no way that this guy is in my Facebook
comments attacking me and my viewers is there.
And indeed, there is.
We you might remember I interviewed this Republican
candidate, Mark Mike CARGILE, not long ago,
and he said that there's satanic people and
there's machines that are bad elections and
all this different stuff and guys completely
unhinged.
And a lot of the stuff Mike Pillow agrees
with.
Check out these comments.
And again, this is a full grown man worth
$300 million and this is how he is spending
hours.
Mike Lindell Yes, David, I believe you need
prayer.
Well, thanks, Mike.
I appreciate your concern.
Mike Pillow showing up and saying I posted
evidence of the voter fraud.
We have to get rid of the machines.
Speaker 2: Over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Mike Pillow continuing and attacking people
and attacking machines saying we need to get
rid of the voting machines.
California has 2.8 million more people on
their voter rolls than people that can vote.
Of course, that's completely untrue.
There is no place, no state that has more
voters than more people registered than actual
legal voters doesn't exist.
Then Mike Lindell started calling people bots.
He called Julie a bot.
He called Blakeson a paid bot.
He said to Norm, we need to get rid of the
voting machines and computers running our
elections.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: He called Susie a paid bot.
He said to me, David, why don't you check
out the evidence?
Well, I would love to.
When I interviewed him, I told him to send
me the evidence after his symposium.
He never did.
Mike Cargill said he would send me the evidence.
Mike focusing in on a guy named Jay and said,
I just posted evidence in this feed.
We have to get rid of the machines.
I see you are a paid bot.
What a shame.
Mike Lindell said to Nancy.
So sad you are a paid bot.
He called Tanya a paid bot.
He called John another paid bot.
He said that pizza is a paid bot.
He said, Chris is a paid bot.
He said Ruth is a paid bot.
He called the auto a paid bot and to stool
array.
He called him a bot with two t's, which I
have to tell you I've never seen.
That's like a double bot of some kind.
Then Mike pillow guys.
Remember, this is an adult worth $300 million.
He started posting a link to some kind of
frank speech interview with a guy named Clint
Curtis, who, again, is one of these whistleblowers
who presents no evidence whatsoever.
He then posted a link about Pete Capps and
Dennis Montgomery, which doesn't actually
provide any evidence of any voter fraud whatsoever.
He then posted a link to his Moment of Truth
Summit, which no one watched.
And then, maybe most importantly, pillow saying,
David, why don't you have me on your horrible
show?
To which I say, pillow.
You're welcome.
Any time, sir.
He's been on before.
I asked him for the evidence.
He didn't send it.
He now seems to be saying he's willing to
be back on.
We are trying to get him back on.
And maybe now he will give me the evidence.
Just a couple other posts.
He then posted a link to some video called
Inside the Machines.
Speaker 2: Over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines.
Speaker 1: Posting over a period of multiple
hours, posting that link many, many times.
Isn't this the strangest thing that we've
ever seen happen?
Like when Alex Jones attacked me.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Your lucky stars every day.
You're not David Pakman.
Yeah.
That is a frickin predator right there.
Speaker 1: Right when Alex Jones attacked
me.
He did it on his own show.
Right.
So he did it for content.
He got something out of it.
Maybe at the end of his attack on me, Alex
Jones sold, you know, some kind of supplement
or something like that.
Pillow is just mixing it up in the YouTube
in the Facebook comments with our own viewers.
I don't see what he could possibly have to
gain from this.
He really this makes me think he's a true
believer.
Let me put it that way.
So there it is.
And we welcome pillow back on the program.
Absolutely any time and hopefully
that
will be soon.